by now you've probably heard about the
terrible acts of ethan crumbly on
november 30th 2021 at oxford high school
it's the latest in a long string of
school shootings in america but what is
legally interesting about this case is
that in addition to filing murder
charges against ethan crumbly oakland
county prosecutor karen mcdonald decided
to charge his parents james and jennifer
crumbly with involuntary manslaughter
with this decision mcdonald broke with
other prosecutors who have in the past
declined to charge parents for the acts
of a child so the question is what if
anything is different about this
particular case and does it signal a
trend towards making parents more
responsible for school shootings
[Music]
as is often the case these days many
people are misunderstanding the charges
that were levied against james and
jennifer crumbly here these charges
hinge on a difficult legal question
could they have reasonably foreseen that
their teenage son would use the gun they
purchased to kill people did they
willfully disregard the results to
others that might follow from their
action or failure to act and here the
prosecutor is arguing that the answer is
yes they knowingly armed a child who had
serious emotional problems and when they
were warned that he was searching for
ammunition and had drawn a violent scene
involving someone being shot they didn't
search ethan's backpack or take him home
the defense lawyers will likely argue
the answer is no the parents locked up
their gun consulted with the school
officials and everyone reached the same
conclusion that there was no risk that
their son would take a gun out and shoot
people which is why he was sent back to
class now millions of parents in byproxy
their children are armed in america and
i'm sure the crumblies will argue that
they had no way to know that this case
would have been different from all of
the other millions of cases that do not
result in intentional homicide here
oakland county filed involuntary
manslaughter charges against jennifer
and james crumbly accusing them of
failing to intervene on the day that
their son killed four people despite
being confronted twice by the school
about their son's interest in weapons
according to the prosecutor on black
friday fifteen-year-old ethan went to
his father james to purchase a nine
millimeter sig sauer from the acme
shooting goods ethan posted a photograph
of the new gun on his social media later
that day the post said my new beauty
with a heart emoji jennifer crumbly
posted that the gun was a christmas
present for ethan and they had enjoyed a
mother-son day at the range on the
following monday november 29th one day
before the shooting a teacher said that
she saw a boy searching online for
ammunition which prompted a meeting with
school officials the school left a
voicemail and sent an email but jennifer
did not respond to the school however
mrs crumbly texted her son quote lowell
i'm not mad at you you have to learn not
to get caught on tuesday morning
november 29th the teacher found a
worksheet on ethan's desk and took a
photo it was a drawing of a gun pointing
at the words the thoughts won't stop
help me there was also a drawing of a
bullet with words above it blood
everywhere there was a person between
the gun and the bullet the person
appears to have been shot twice ethan
allegedly wrote my life is useless the
teacher contacted the dean of students
and the school counselor they called the
crumblies for an emergency meeting at
the school meanwhile ethan was placed in
the counseling room with his backpack
the counselor obtained the drawing but
ethan had already scratched out portions
he allegedly said the drawing was part
of a video game that he was designing
that he wanted a career as a video game
designer ethan stayed in the office for
approximately 90 minutes working on his
science assignment according to the
superintendent the counselors didn't
believe that he would harm others based
on his behavior or his demeanor the
crumblies arrived at the school around
10 30 am school officials showed james
and jennifer the note they asked ethan
whether he wanted to harm himself or
others and based on his answers the
parents of school officials assumed that
he was not a threat the crumblies
resisted the idea of their son leaving
the school and returning to an empty
house the school told the parents to get
ethan into counseling within 48 hours
according to superintendent tim thorne
the school permitted ethan to return to
class because he had no disciplinary
history at about 12 51 pm ethan crumbly
emerged from a school bathroom with a
gun his father bought him four days
before he fired at students in the
hallway killing four and wounding six
students and one teacher after the
shooting made the news jennifer texted
ethan crumbly at 1 22 pm quote ethan
don't do it just 15 minutes later james
calls 9-1-1 to report a gun was missing
from his house and he believed his son
might be the shooter the crumbly said
that the gun had been kept in a locked
drawer in the parents bedroom so one of
the things that's interesting here is
that the parents are not being charged
by virtue of being parents but rather
because of the actions they took in
general it's not a case of charging the
parents for what the child did in other
words the argument is that if anyone
took the alleged actions that the
crumblies took they could be charged
with the same thing regardless of
whether they were the parents or not now
to understand this distinction and
understand what is happening in this
case we need to talk about the different
kinds of homicide in michigan so first
we start with murder first degree murder
is defined as a killing perpetrated by
means of poison lying in wait or any
other willful deliberate and
premeditated killing premeditated means
the person thought about committing the
murder before the act this can take
place
weeks or months ahead of time or it can
take place
one second before it for example a
michigan man named carell burns was
convicted of first-degree murder after
he made up a story about a robbery to
lure his friend into an alley where he
purposefully shot and killed him burns
said that he was acting on the orders of
a business associated but he still
created a plan for the murder ahead of
time and this is a classic example of
premeditation and although the burns
case is what most people think about
when they hear the words premeditation
the term also applies when someone
quickly makes up their mind to kill
someone often in a split second and here
ethan crumbly is charged with four
counts of first-degree murder and
several counts of attempted murder so no
surprise there then we get to
manslaughter in contrast manslaughter is
murder without malice manslaughter
offenses are not premeditated
manslaughter is generally defined as the
crime of killing a human being without
malice a forethought or otherwise in
circumstances not accounting to murder
michigan's criminal statutes do not give
a precise definition of manslaughter as
a result michigan courts look to the
common law to
define traditional categories of
manslaughter that is voluntary
manslaughter and involuntary
manslaughter in michigan uh voluntary
manslaughter is often a heat of passion
crime it differs from first-degree
murder because the intent to kill was
formed when the defendant had a
sun-violent and irresistible passion
caused by some sort of provocation this
provocation or excitement has to happen
almost immediately without the chance
for the person to cool down and if the
person had enough time to get their
emotions under control and they still
decide to kill another person then that
is actual murder now involuntary
manslaughter occurs during an accidental
or non-intentional death where the
defendant had no intent to cause someone
else's death but their reckless act
winds up resulting in death involuntary
manslaughter can also happen during an
unlawful act that is a misdemeanor or
low-level felony like a doi perhaps the
most classic example of involuntary
manslaughter is when someone is drunk
and gets behind the wheel and then kills
another person in a car accident since
everyone is presumed to know that
driving while under the influence of
alcohol or drugs is reckless and puts
others in danger the resulting fatality
is often charged as involuntary
manslaughter now other reckless acts or
emissions can lead to criminal charges
too for example if you decided to blow
up a giant firework in a crowded space
and someone is hit and killed
that would probably be involuntary
manslaughter too or potentially
something even more serious you might
not have meant to kill a certain person
in the crowd but since it's so dangerous
to engage in that activity you would
probably be charged with involuntary
manslaughter now under michigan law to
convict someone of involuntary
manslaughter a prosecutor must prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that the
defendant caused the death of the victim
that in doing the act that caused the
victim's death the defendant acted in a
grossly negligent manner and that the
defendant caused the death without
lawful excuse or justification now
proving someone else's acts or omissions
actually caused someone else's death is
not an easy task especially when the
people who were charged didn't commit
the physical acts that led to the death
so in this case that means the
prosecution has to prove that ethan
crumbly's intentional acts did not break
the chain of causation that started when
the parents purchased the gun the jury
instruction on causation explains it is
not enough that the defendant's act made
it possible for the death to occur in
order to find that the death was caused
by the defendant you must find beyond
reasonable doubt that the death was the
natural and necessary result of the
defendant's act now here the prosecutor
can show that the sun easily obtained
the gun as a direct result of the
parents actions but that's not nearly
enough the prosecutor will probably also
make the case that the crumbles failed
to secure the weapon that
the weapon wasn't locked up or if it was
it wasn't properly secured and their son
had easy access to the gun but in the
crumbly's defense their lawyers will
probably argue that the school didn't
warn the parents he had threatened to
use a firearm that their complaint was
only that he had made a drawing with
violent imagery including a firearm
which
probably millions of young boys are
doing every single day and while he was
arguably fantasizing about killing the
school and the parents concluded that he
wasn't a threat to himself or others and
ethan's internet search for ammo was
just that a search and of course there
are many legal reasons to use ammunition
in a gun i'm sure they'll argue that
given the short history of the whole
family going to the shooting range that
the most likely conclusion is that ethan
crumbly was searching for ammunition to
use at the range as they had done in the
past on top of that to prove the crime
of involuntary manslaughter the state
has to prove that the crumblies acted
with gross negligence not simple
negligence where you act unreasonably
but gross negligence means more than
carelessness it means willfully
disregarding the results to others that
might follow from an act or failure to
act the prosecution must also prove that
to a reasonable person it would have
been apparent that the result was likely
to be serious injury to another person
and this is a very difficult case just
because the crumblies didn't act as
another person might doesn't necessarily
mean that they acted with gross
negligence and assuming that the
crumblies did not lock up their gun
would that itself constitute gross
negligence well in many states it is a
crime to not properly store a firearm
when there is a child in the home but
michigan does not have any child access
prevention laws that doesn't mean it's
per se unlawful for the crumblies to
carelessly store their firearm and of
course the crumblings do not admit that
they were negligent in storing their gun
and ammunition and of course not
searching ethan crumbly's backpack under
these circumstances is also a point of
contention i'm sure the prosecution will
argue that failing to search the
backpack was also grossly negligent but
under these circumstances the crumblies
allegedly didn't find out that their gun
was missing until after the school
shooting had already started and of
course the school didn't search the
backpack either though there is one
other issue that may hurt the crumbly's
defense and that is their attempt to
evade arrest when there's evidence the
defendant tried to run away or escape
after they were accused of a crime or
police attempt to make an arrest that
can be used against the defendant in
court as proof that they had
consciousness of guilt after the
prosecutor announced the parents would
be charged the parents withdrew four
thousand dollars and hid in a detroit
warehouse the crumbly's lawyer said that
they were not fleeing from police and
they left town because of violent
threats although their lawyer said the
couple was preparing to turn themselves
in the circumstances of their capture
don't look good now while the
circumstances of this case are unusual
and no doubt will be difficult for
prosecutors there is some precedent for
charging parents in somewhat similar
circumstances in 2020 jemele james
pleaded no contest to involuntary
manslaughter after a six-year-old child
in his home shot and killed another
six-year-old child kayla roland at
school in that case a witness
demonstrated how they had seen james and
another man who stayed in the house
playing with a gun twirling it in their
hands now other adults have been charged
with involuntary manslaughter for not
securing their guns but prosecutors tend
to charge adults only when the shooter
was someone very young as in the rolling
case and that's because the law presumes
that children that young can't form
criminal intent but the same isn't true
of a teenager who can form their own
criminal intent teens are presumed to
have agency which means that the chain
of causation between the adults and the
homicide is usually broken but there's
no doubt that this is a tragic situation
and it's because of things like this
that i think about trying to do the most
good in this world and i've long been a
supporter of effective altruism and
today's sponsor givewell makes that a
reality because givewell spends over 20
000 hours each year researching
charitable organizations and only
recommends a few of the highest impact
evidence-based charities that they've
found over 50 000 donors have used
givewell to donate more than 750 million
dollars and ensure that their donations
made the maximum impact to save tens of
thousands of lives and improve the lives
of millions of others and here's the
best part givewell is completely free it
helps you allocate tax deductible
donations to the charity that you choose
without taking a cut they publish all of
their research and recommendations on
their site for free no sign up required
and when you donate through givewell
your donations are still tax-deductible
in the united states givewell's top
recommendation is to donate to their
maximum impact fund which directs
donations to the charity or charities
that givewell has determined to be the
most effective each quarter and givewell
is completely transparent about how
their donations are spent and how their
decisions are made they even have a web
page devoted to sharing the mistakes
they've made along the well and it
simplifies the process of finding and
giving to outstanding charities because
they do the independent research
givewell gives me the peace of mind that
my donations are doing the maximum good
they do the evidence-based research that
i would want to do if i had the time and
this is incredible givewell is matching
donations from first-time donors dollar
for dollar up to two hundred and fifty
dollars all you have to do is click on
the link that's on screen right now or
in the description to donate and be sure
to use the fundraiser code legaleagle at
checkout to make sure that your donation
gets matched again to have up to 250
dollars matched just click on the link
and use the code legaleagle and while
you're there click on this playlist with
all my other real law reviews for more
legal analysis of the most important
legal news